Transcriber: Dania Rashwani
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
في آخر يوم دراسة لي في الفصل الأول كنت قد
قررت أن أنسحب
عندما كان عمري سنتين
اكتشفنا وجود ورم بالحبل الشوكي فقمنا
باستئصاله للمرة الأولى
ولكنه عاد واستئصلناه للمرة الثانية،
وعاد مرة أخرى
وقمنا باستئصاله للمرة الثالثة والأخيرة،
وأنا عمري إحدى عشر سنة
لكن للأسف صحة الإنسان لما تصاب بعلّة
لا تعود مثل الأول
وكل هذه الأورام أخلفت عندي
ما يسمى بالقدم العصبية
قدم عصبية يعني قدم فاقدة الأعصاب و الإحساس
فيها، قد تحرق قدمي ولا أشعر،
ممكن قدمي تنجرح وتنزف وأيضاً لا أشعر
وفعلاً هذا اللي صار بيوم من الأيام
وأنا عائدة من المدرسة في الصف السادس
خلعت الحذاء ووجدت قدمي كلها دم .
وخفتت .
لكني لم أعي أنني أعيش باللحظة التي سوف
تقودني لأصعب قدرٍ في حياتي بعد سنوات.
لففت قدمي بالضماد في غرفتي
في سنة ألفين أحدى عشر .
فككت الضماد و أنا على سرير العملية قبل بضع
دقائق من عملية البتر لقدمي
في سنة ألفين و عشرين.
التسع سنوات تلك، هي أكثر بكثير من تسع
سنوات، هي ثلاثين عملية وثلاثين أمل
وثلاثين رحلة علاج .
ثلاثين مرة تكلمت فيها مع نفسي
هل يا ترى قد ينجح العلاج!
ممكن بكره يكون أحسن.
تم تشخيصي بما يسمى كالكينيس أوستومالايتيس
والتي تعني التهاب في عظم الكعب.
والجرح الذي رأيته أول يوم،
كان قد تحوّل لتقرح مزمن.
كانت رحلة علاجي تبدأ من عملية،
وبعدها أدوية ثم وجع ومبيت طويل بالمستشفى
واستخدام للعكازات
وكل هذا يحتاج فترة ثلاثة عشر
أسبوع إلى فترة غير محددة.
ومواجهتي للعلاج والتتعامل معه من جانب،
ومواجهة مجتمعي والحياة التي أريد أن أكملها
كان من جانب آخر.
أتذكر وأنا في الصف السادس قالت لي إحدى
أصدقائي
لا تعتقدي أننا أصدقائك لأننا نحبك ... لا
نحن أصدقاؤك لأننا نشفق عليك لأنك معاقة
جملتها وقتها أثرت حتى بنظرتي لنفسي
أصبحت أريد أن أجتهد في العلاج أكثر،
وأريد أن أتوقف عن استخدم العكاز
وأن لا أعرج
حتى أصبح طبيعية كما يريدوني الناس أن أكون.
مع الوقت استطعت أن أتقبّل
العلاج وأتقبل العكار.
لكن تقبلي لتلك الفتيات في الحقيقة
كان نابع من فكرة
أنني تعودت على فتيات مدرستي وعلى بيئتهم،
فالتحدي الحقيقي كان عندما انتقلت ندى
لتصبح طالبة جامعية.
في أول فصل دراسي لي،
حاولت أن أعتزل العلاج،
أردت أن أحاول فقط أن أعيش
بعد سبع سنوات من الحياة المستمرة
في المستشفيات وفي الأدوية أرت فقط أن أعيش
وهذا الشيء كان ثمنه كبيراً، بآخر يوم
في الفصل الدراسي الأول،
وفي أثناء خروجي من بوابة الجامعة
كنت أحاول أن أرفع قدمي و أمشي بخطوة واحدة
لأصل إلى البوابة ولكن ام أستطع
،فذهبت إلى مبنى ادارة الجامعة
وقدمت طلب انسحاب، وذهبت عند أهلي في البيت،
وقلت لهم:
لن أكمل تعليمي حتى أنتهي من علاج،
لأنني لا أستطيع المضي قدماً.
وما بين ألم العلاج الذي بدأت به مباشرةً،
وما بين ألم الوحدة والفراغ والحياة
التي ليس لها معنى.
واخذتني هذه العزلة لأفكر
أنني أنا ندى ... لست وحيدة.
وأن الإنسان قيمته من قيمة الأشياء التي
فقدها بحياته، وليس بالأشياء التي امتلكها
فعندما يفقد ويعاني عندها يفكر بالتغيير
فيصنع هذه القيمة.
فهنا كانت مبادرة عون، مبادرة عون هي
مبادرة تهدف لتقديم  المساعدة والدعم
للأشخاص من ذوي الإعاقة
في داخل حرم الجامعة.
وفي بداية السنة الثانية كان العلاج  نفسه
والعكازات لم تتغير والوجع نفسه،
ولكن أنا ندى لم أعد نفسي.
أيقنت بأن الإنسان إذا أراد أن ينتظر ظرف
معين بحياته أن ينتهي ...
ليحقق شيء بحياته فلن يحققه أبداً في حياته.
وسوف يأتي عليه يوم يجد فيه نفسه قد أصبح
كتلة من الأحلام المؤجلة،
وأن جميع الأوقات مناسبة
متى ما أراد الإنسان.
فعدت وسجلت في الجامعة
واخترت أن أكمل مهما كانت الظروف .
وفي نفس الوقت قدمت مبادرة عون
على برنامج اسم الوي إل بي
تابع إلى اليو إن دي بي،
وتم اختيارها لتمثل فلسطين إقليمياً
على مستوى الوطن العربي،
وكانت هذه السنة في الأردن.
وعندما تواصلوا معي و قالوا لي:
نريد أن تذهبي إلى الأردن
ترددت في البداية، ولكن تذكرت أنه
دائماً ما تمنيت أن أسجّل بمخيم صيفي
ولكن ولم يحدث ذلك في حياتي بسبب العلاج،
وتذكرت أني انسحبت من الجامعة بسبب العلاج،
وانسحبت من أشياء كثيرة في حياتي بسببه.
ولن أستمر في الإنسحاب أكتر من ذلك فوافقت.
وعندما عدت من رحلتي في الأردن تذكرت عندما
كنت رافضة أن أذهب بالعكازات إلى المدرسة.
أنا هلأ والجبص في قدمي والإبر بيداي
والعكازات تحت اكتافي اخترت
أن أذهب إلى دولة أخرى لوحدي
وهنا كان الدرس الكبير لي بأن طاقة
الإنسان ليس لها نهاية ولا تعرف حدود،
تعيش اليوم في صراع مع نفسك على شيء صغيرة،
لكن غداً ستكون قوياً أمام صراع أكبر منه.
فتقبلي للعلاج ليس معناه أني في داخلي رفض
لهذا الحل الجذري يعني صراحةً أنا ندى،
كنت أريد أن أتوقف عن الذهاب إلى المستشفى
لم أعد أريد الذاب للمستشفيات أكثر من ذلك،
ففي ذلك الوقت
على مدار سنة ونصف كنت في كل لحظة
أفكر بفكرة البتر القدم .
لكن أيضا على مدار السنة ونصف تلك،
و لا مرة في حياتي شعرت أنني أمتلك الجرأة
لأتكلم بهذه الفكرة بصوت عالي.
حتى يوم في الشهر السادس ألفين وعشرين،
كنت عند طبيبي وقلت له:
قد أجريت أكثر من ثلاثين عملية
أريد حلاً نهائياً.
أنا تعبت .
الشهر صار سنة والسنة صارت تسع سنين.
يكفي إلى هنا.
قال لي: ندى لقد أجريت ثلاثين عملية وقد
تقومين بعمل ثلاثمئة أخرى
وضعك مزمن، والحل الجذري الوحيد هو ...
البتر .
عندما قالها بدأت أرتجف.
ومباشرة اتجهت عيناي نحو أبي
لأرى ردة فعله على الفكرة.
لكن وبعد قليل شعرت براحة في داخلي
لأن أحد ما أخذ العبئ عني وتكلّم
وقال تلك الفكرة بصوت عالي
وقبل أن أقرر اتخاذ القرار
كان يجب أن أخبرهم أن الإنسان
عندما يريد أن ينهي طريق بحياته،
يجب أن يكون قد وضع كل الأمل والطاقة
حتى ينجح هذا الطريق،
فحاولت معالجة قدمي
للمرة الأخيرة في شهر ثمانية ولكن لم تنجح.
فى بداية شهر اثنا عشر
وضعت موضوع البتر أمامي
كقرار جدي وحقيقي.
وآمنت بأن المعرفة سلاح، حتى أستطيع
أن أتجاوز هذه التجربة.
لكن ما أكن أعرف كل شيء عنها ، يجب
أن أكون درس قرار من كل النواحي.
تعرفت على شخص عنده بتر .
وسألته عن أبسط شغل في حياته وأبسط ممارسات
في حياته،
وذهبت إلى مراكز أطراف وسألت عن التأهيل
وتكلمت مع معالج نفسي من حيث طبيعة
العلاج الطبيعي وكل شيء.
حتى ليلة من الليالي و أنا أقرأ في كتاب
فوجدت دراسة
تتكلم أن الضفدع من الحيوانات التي تأقلم
درجة حرارة جسمها مع درجة حرارة المكان.
وفي إحدى التجارب وضعوا الضفدع
في ماء وأشعلوا النار تحته.
وكانت كلما ترتفع درجة حرارة الماء
يؤقلم الضفدع درجة حرارة جسمه
على درجة حرارة الماء
حتى وصلت درجة الغليان ولم يستطع التحمل،
فحاول أن يقفز ولكنه لم يستطع.
وبالتالي فقد مات ...
لو سألنا ما الذي قتل الضفدع؟
سنقول الماء المغلي.
لكن فعلياً الذي قتله
هو أنه أهدر طاقته
في محاولة التأقلم وعدم أخذه لقرار القفز
في الوقت المناسب عندما كان لديه
فرصة في إنقاذ حياته.
التأقلم شيء جميل والإنسان الذكي هو الذي
يستطيع أن يتأقلم في الظروف المختلفة،
لكن لا تسمح للتأقلم أن يأخذ كل طاقتك.
يجب أن تخبئ طاقة لمرحلة القفز في حال
فشل التأقلم، وجميعنا هنا نملك هذا الحق
سواء بوظيفة أو بتخصص أو بمرض
أو بعلاقة في حياتنا.
وهنا ندى عندما أجريت اتصالاً مع الدكتور
وقلت له:
أنا أريد أن أذهب لحياة جديدة،
أريد أن تحجز لي موعد لعملية البتر.
ولن أدعي البطولة،
فبين اللحظة التي تكلمت فيها مع الطبيب
وبين اللحظة التي عاود فيها الطبيب مكالمتي،
ليخبرني أن غداً عمليتك
كان أسبوع صعب جداً، وفي يوم العملية
مشيت بخطوات ثقيلة جداً في غرفة العمليات
وعندما استيقظت كان أهلي يترقبون ردّة
فعلي
وينظرون إلي، ويتساءلون ماذا ستكون
ردّة فعلي،
صراحةً وبكل صدق، الشعور الوحيد الذي
شعرت به
كان أن يد الله كانت تحميني.
وشعرت بسكينة ورضاء وشعرت أن الصبر
كان يحاوطني من كل ناحية.
وفي الليل أخذت أنا وأبي قدمي
وذهبنا ودفناها في التراب.
وفي المكان الذي دفناها فيه، زرعنا شجرة.
وقال لي والدي أوعديني أن هذه الشجرة كل مرة
ستكبرفيها
أنت أيضاً سوف تكبرين و تكملين الطريق.
واليوم أنا ندى، من الصحيح أن قدمي
في التراب ...
لكن البصيرة التي زرعتها في داخلي
سأحملها معي طوال عمري.
إذا تسمحون لي بكلمة أخيرة
لأنني ...
في هذه اللحظة كنت أعلم أنني سأبكي
(تصفيق)
عندما علمت أن لدي ورم وأنا عمري سنتين،
قلت لوالدي:
لا يهمني أن تعيش عمرها كله على كرسي،
الذي يهمني فقط، عندما تنظر في المرآة تقول:
أنا أحب هذه الإنسانة وراضية عنها،
وبفضل ربنا ونتيجة لصبركم وإيمانكم وتضحيتكم
تلك السنوات ...
الذي وصلت له اليوم أكثر بكثير
من أنني راضة عن نفسي.
فشكرا لكم وشكرا لكل أهل يعززون قيمة
أولادهم مهما كانوا،
ولا يهمهم أي شيء،
(تصفيق)
غير أن أولادهم عندما
يكبرون ينظرون في المرآة ويقولون:
أنا أحب هذا الإنسان وراض عنه
وشكراً.